one of the industries which has just
exploded in growth this year
is telehealth according to the medical
economics 2020 health
ehr survey more than 77 percent of
doctors surveyed
used telehealth for the very first time
because of covet 19. so
gone are the days when you need to make
an appointment and wait weeks to get
into a doctor's office
in today's health watch online provider
nurex says this type of care
is here to stay copit has really shined
a light on how you can get personalized
quality care with telehealth nurex
serves 300
000 patients a month and is growing
instead of being a second or third
choice for care
nurex ceo varsha rao believes it's now
the first
choice for many women so all you do is
you fill out a medical history online
just like you would when you arrive at a
doctor's office
but then you chat or private message
with a provider
patients always have the opportunity to
ask questions
and to have interactions and many times
our patients are telling us that our
providers are giving them more
information better
information more education than what
they're getting in in-person settings
now some health insurance companies do
include telehealth as a benefit
in fact a study done this summer shows
physicians are still concerned about the
security of it
the workflow integration and also being
reimbursed for telehealth
even though 76 percent of people are
interested in it just 46 percent of
people surveyed
actually used it but that could change
as we continue to move through this
world in a post-pandemic world